[Music]
this world is not yet ready for all that
you will do
the time will come diana
and everything will be different
[Music]
citizens of the world i'm here to change
your life
anything you want
anything you dream of you can have it
look like you saw ghost
diana lucky you it's like now one day
has passed
i don't want to be like anyone i want to
be an
apex predator
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
well now that's my turn
get used to it
i've never been one for rules the answer
is always
more
the way i fly they will never find us i
forgot to tell you what
radar will they will they shoot at us
[Applause]
[Music]
barbara what did you do
you know i'm not so keen on this one i
figure uh you are but
you know what i'm ready to go i think we
can do better
parachute pants yeah um does everybody
parachute now
my life hasn't been what you probably
think
it has we all have our struggles
have you ever been in love a long long
time ago
you so many times yeah all the time
welcome to the future life is good but
it can be better
and why shouldn't it be
all you need is to want
think about finally having everything
you always
wanted i can save today
but you can
now i take what i want in return
everyone will see
i need you
you know you need to do
nothing good is born from lies
and greatness is not what you think
[Music]
it's all art
it's ah that's just a trash can it's
just a trash can yeah yeah
[Music]
you